I honestly didn't think it would be that
easy I almost didn't listen to you guys
like thank goodness I read my comments
so if anything just let this video kind
of be a reminder to you that you should
properly evaluate certain things like
actually give it like some time before
you decide that that's not an
appropriate solution for you all right
what's up guys my name is the Cho and
I'm building a game engine that's going
to be my intro probably from now
on so for those of you a little bit out
of the loop I have been setting up like
some kind of automated testing situation
for hazel the game mention that I'm
building because I want to reduce some
of the pressures of testing from the
team and I'll have the previous video
linked up there suggest you check it out
because it explains a lot more about the
context of what's going on but the goal
at the moment is that every time someone
commits some code anyone on the team
commits some code to Hazel pushes some
new code we want to like run that code
we want to make sure that it compiles on
all like build configurations all
platforms that kind of thing and then we
want to also like run the engine test it
and make sure that that code hasn't
broken anything it's obviously very
useful if that just happens
automatically behind the scenes any time
new code is pushed and once that kind of
infrastructure is in place it can extend
a little bit more so for example if
someone's proposing code changes in the
form of like a pull request that can
actually be evaluated first to make sure
it integrates nicely and all the tests
pass and the code compiles and all of
that stuff before a human even needs to
like dedicate time and read that code
and make sure that it works kind of
using their own eyes so in summary it's
all about reducing the need for human
resources and in that last video I was
discussing my thought process of how we
would even integrate a system like this
and there was something called GitHub
actions which I kind of took a brief
look at but then ultimately decided that
seems too complicated like I got to set
up all these like scripts and install
stuff on my computer why don't I just
write a simple python script that just
pulls P the repository sees that there
are new commits on a particular Branch
pulls the code down you know runs it
that kind of stuff and that was
basically what I had settled on in fact
Peter and I even talked about it and we
decided that this was just going to be
so much easier why wouldn't we just go
down this Roots it it just sounds like
setting that up would just be more
complex why wouldn't we just do it this
way and then the next morning I woke up
and what tends to happen sometimes
actually probably more often than I'd
like to admit I'm lying aake in bed at
night and I'm just almost almost
subconsciously thinking about stuff and
I was thinking about Hazel and all of
these thoughts were kind of coming into
my head and I was like but you know it
would be really nice to use GitHub
actions and everyone in the comments
like seems to be telling me that it's
not that hard like are they really all
wrong like wouldn't it be nice to
integrate this better with GitHub so
that for example anyone on the team can
easily view logs and build statuses and
and we would get that kind of direct
communication between GitHub the
repository and the actual like Ci
machine this guy over here it's
obviously just a more robust system
would it really be that difficult to set
up no no turns out it's really easy
turns out it's really easy I don't know
I think sometimes it's easy to kind of
be lazy and assume that oh whatever
that's too difficult I'll just do it the
way that I know how to do it without
daring to venture in a little bit deeper
and potentially learn something new like
I'm definitely guilty of that so if
anything just let this video kind of be
a reminder to you that you should
properly evaluate certain things like
actually give it like some time before
you decide that that's not an
appropriate solution for you so
yesterday Friday morning I just moted up
the qap and I was like I'm going to give
GitHub actions a fgo like I'm going to
spend like at least the whole morning
going through and trying to set this up
because ultimately like I'm aware of all
the benefits that it provides it's just
that I was a little bit scared of the
kind of upfront cost of setting it up I
guess but then also deploying it to more
and more PCS that we would have to do
we'd have to get more devices to test
Hazel and I was a little bit worried
that it might not be as configurable as
easy to spin up a new pc and get it to
run all of these things and compile the
code but no I think it's going to
completely satisfy all of our needs and
goals it is in fact very flexible and
very configurable and so the rest of
this video I'm going to talk about how I
set this up yesterday and how it's
currently functioning and our plans for
it in the future as well so before we
jump on this computer and I show you in
depth everything the main kind of
takeaway here is that this is just a
self-hosted runner and the process is
really simple your repository just needs
some kind of workflow file and that
workflow file just defines like I guess
what actions need to be taken to
complete that workflow and so once you
kind of have literally a series of steps
of what you want it to do as well as
when to do it so for example when
there's a push event when someone pushes
code into the repository I would like to
complete the following steps once you
have that you then need to get something
like some form of Runner or you know
device to actually kind of listen for
those events and then execute your steps
for you now that can be either a GitHub
hosted Runner or it can be a self-hosted
runner we went for a self-hosted runner
because it made a lot more sense first
of all it's completely free because
you're the one providing the hardware
not GitHub so you're not paying like
essentially a price per minute of that
kind of Hardware being allocated for you
by GitHub there are free minutes
included of course but that's kind of
besides the point because we know that
we want to control the hardware we have
the hardware and we need it to be a
little bit more customizable than
perhaps GitHub can offer us because what
we're testing here is a game engine we
want it to be able to run with specific
gpus and drivers and kind of record
frame rates and the environment
definitely needs to be controlled by us
so of course we went the self-hosted
runner route I did by the way mention
this in the previous video I I added a
little note there being like yeah we
could do a self-hosted runner but it'd
probably be more trouble than it's worth
if this is the computer that needs to
run that stuff then uh I guess GitHub
actions goes out the window at least as
far as I'm aware I don't know maybe I'm
missing something that's always possible
you guys can always let me know I was
wrong it happens we all make mistakes
I'm just glad I was able to kind of fix
this quickly and early so anyway for a
self-hosted runner all you need to do is
so step one here we have the Hazel
repository this is the one you can get
on patreon.com theano if you help
support the project this is the full
version of Hazel and by the way once you
do sign up on patreon all you have to do
is go to get. haas.com connect your
patreon and GitHub accounts and you will
automatically get invited into this
repository so it's a really kind of
instant process now back in the day you
had to message me on patreon wait like
up to a week potentially for me to give
you access doesn't work like that
anymore so inside this repository if you
go to settings this is really like step
one if you want to do this your set self
if you go down here to actions you have
to basically enable actions so disable
actions was kind of the default for this
repository I had to not only allow
Studio Cho actions and reusable
workflows which is what I thought you
had to do because this says that any
action or reusable workflow defined in a
repository within studio cha can be used
but then I was actually getting errors
saying that hey you're using stuff that
isn't in studio cha which didn't make
sense to me because I was like no no the
workflow file which I'll show you in a
minute here was inside a studio Channel
repository but it's because I was using
actions that were kind of on the
marketplace as it's called basically I
was using an action at that time called
checkout which just clones the
repository you think that was like just
a normal thing but that action I guess
technically isn't my action I'm kind of
importing it as like an external package
almost and so for that you need to allow
non Studio Cher actions that are either
created by GitHub or allow actions by
Marketplace verified creators so that
needed to be done before it would
actually run my kind of build action
successfully so that's worth noting once
that is done you know if you go back to
your repository you'll see that there is
an actions tab so over here you just
click on actions and here we have kind
of the dashboard of all workflows and
here's our build workflow we'll get into
that in a minute but the first thing
that I ended up doing was back here in
settings under actions there's this
section called Runners so under Runners
you can see we can host our own Runners
here I had to click new self-hosted
Runner and then the set up is really
easy for that so this is how we kind of
download essentially an application onto
our computer that turns it into this
kind of self-hosted Runner it's
basically just a little app that you
would typically run as like a Windows
service so that it's kind of
persistently running and it will
basically communicate with GitHub
there's a lot of documentation I might
leave it below if you want to read about
how it actually does the communication
and stuff but the gist is just that it
will communicate with GitHub in doing so
it will be able to pick up events such
as push events and then it will execute
whatever work workflows you define right
here on this computer so that's kind of
what it is it's a runner it will run
whatever workflow you define on this
computer when certain events happen and
it does so by communicating with GitHub
so we have Mac OS Linux Windows you can
select whatever architecture you want as
well these commands are really all you
have to execute I made a directory
called actions Runner here it is kind of
on my local C drive just at the root uh
because it said on a drive route so I
was like whatever I'll make it there and
then you can see this is what downloads
the actual Runner so you just like run
this in Powershell or just like in the
ter app which typically is Powershell or
Windows Powershell to be exact you can
optionally validate the hash if you like
to make sure you downloaded the full
file and then this will just extract the
installer finally you just run config
with a token that I probably shouldn't
show you guys I don't actually know if
that's secret or not but I'll blur it
anyway so yeah just run this config
which is you can see over here uh kind
of in these extracted files that you've
just downloaded and then you just run it
and that's kind of it so that's the
entire setup you would need to do if you
wanted to get like a new node or a new
computer being a self-hosted runner uh
for Linux and for Mac OS similar setup
which is important because I'm
definitely going to be doing this on
Linux in the future but for now we're
just setting it up on windows so you can
see also it says here use this yaml in
your workflow file for each job because
basically when you set up a runner it
gets a series of labels and if we
actually go back to Runners you can see
that this studio Cho QA which is just
the name of this computer that has these
kind of labels attached to it
self-hosted Windows x64 that's nice
because you can Define certain workflows
that only run on certain labels
basically so like only run this workflow
on a self-hosted runner or only run this
workflow on a Windows Runner so there's
all these talk of workflows so what
actually are they and how do you set
them up because that's kind of the
important thing that dictates when to
perform what so that also is rather
simple if we go to actions we can create
a new workflow and then you basically
choose a workflow to start with and
these workflows are just kind of defined
by yaml files which is great because cuz
I love the Amel format and I think it's
really simple and easy to understand and
easy to read so what did I start with
well we we don't use make so I kind of
just wanted to see in general what C++
workflows do you have and then I found
Ms build based projects which is perfect
because we use Visual Studio to build
Hazel and Ms build is obviously the
compiler that Visual Studio uses for you
know building stuff so I just used this
as a starting point that's basically
what it is when you hit configure here
you can see it's made a new workflow
under your repository under do GitHub
workflows here it is you can call it
whatever you want it's a gam file and
this is kind of the code that it gave
you so this was my starting point uh
which is great because you can see that
it does two kind of critical things or
three critical things even first of all
it uses this actions checkout now
checkout V3 is not the latest version V4
is so I went ahead and updated that
actions checkout what this is and where
it kind of exists is over here so
github.com actions checkout this is the
repository check out V4 that's the
latest version as of me recording this
it tells you how to use this which is
great so I definitely consulted this
because I needed much more than just a
simple checkout and I'll show you my
yaml file in a minute I'm just kind of
talking about the journey so that's
obviously very important because that
checks out you know the repository that
does a clone of the repository so that
you have the repository now on your
selfhosted Runner then the next critical
thing that it does is it adds Ms build
to path and again if you want to look at
this you just go to github.com
microsofts setup Ms build yeah here's
the repository and you can figure out
how to use it uh you know new get
packages didn't need that we don't have
any and then the other critical thing
that it does for us is you can see that
it runs Ms build in the working
directory which is basically where it
checked out the code to so this is that
directory that you checked the code out
to and it will basically build whatever
build configuration you specified over
here and whatever solution file path you
specified over here so this was a really
really good starting point you can also
see up here that this is what it does
these jobs on so on push event for which
branch for me I made it Dev because
that's how kind of branch that I wanted
to test Master is already our release
Branch so the only stuff really going
into that branch is stuff that's already
been tested and it's effectively
released so very rarely code is actually
pushed there Dev is definitely the
branch that you know gets commits almost
every day I want to test that now the
idea is you set this up however you like
I'll kind of move it over here you can
commit the changes right from here you
just press commit changes you add
whatever commit message you want oh by
the way if you want to change the branch
that it goes to uh you can just hit this
files and then this is how I changed it
you know to be in the dev branch and so
now you can see we're in Dev and we can
commit the changes like directly to Dev
so that's where I put it but you
basically just do that and then like
that's it as long as your Runner is
running as a Windows service um well
actually you don't even have to run it
like you could just hit run for example
and you can see It'll connect to GitHub
it'll give me an error here in a minute
saying that it's already running because
it is but you can run it from here you
don't have to run it as a service but
typically it does install it as a
service um and that's good because you
can see we have this GitHub actions
Runner here now I did did have to make
one change uh and that was I had to
basically change this log on it was
running this as like a limited access
kind of network Authority account I
changed it to be local system account
which gave it admin rights and that was
necessary for a couple things first of
all because I added a step where it
downloaded and installed a particular
version of python because we use Python
to run like all of our kind of setup
scripts that requires admin rights so I
had to change that but then also Hazel's
own setup Scripts also creates symbolic
links in order to kind of avoid copying
some files and those symbolic links
require admin privileges as well so
that's what I had to do to the service
but otherwise that's kind of it every
time you now push it will run this stuff
and you'll be able to see every run
inside this actions tab so now let's
quickly take a look before we explore
the actions tab a little bit more deeply
let's take a look at what our yaml file
actually looks like so this is it uh
this is the complete yaml file I called
it build pretty self-explanatory you can
see it's being triggered on a push to
the dev branch and inside the
environment all I've specified is the
solution file path if you are paying
attention you'd notice that I removed
the release configuration but we'll see
where that's gone later permissions I
left on read which basically just allows
it to read the contents of this
repository I don't need it to write
anything to the repository and then here
is the job so you can define a series of
jobs here but we only have one job it's
called build and this kind of defines
all of it so if we take a look at this
this build job runs on Windows and
self-host again what that means is if we
go back to the runners you can see this
has both the selfhosted and the windows
label so that basically means that this
workflow can run on this Runner and if
we had like some non- self-hosted
runners in the future for example this
wouldn't run on that because I only
really want to run this on like this
computer and then we have something
called a strategy and that's because I
wanted to set up a matrix now there's
some great documentation on this stuff
which I highly recommend you take a look
at basically the reason why I did this
was because I knew that this wasn't just
as simple as I want to build debug and
that's it I wanted to build debug
release and dist I wanted to build all
of these configurations and so what a
matrix lets you do is it lets you
basically specify a series of different
parameters and it will automatically run
every possible combination of these so
if I also had some other like defin
specified let's say for example actually
probably the documentation is probably
more useful so this example here where
we have two different os's and three
different versions it's going to run
that six times because it's going to run
these three versions for this and then
these three versions for this so every
kind of possible permutation is going to
be run now in this case it's only kind
of onedimensional we just got these
three but it will basically run these
potentially in parallel and show the
results to me as like three different
kind of runs of this workflow so that's
really helpful because of course I need
to test all of these so here's our
actions checkout 4 so this will check
out I don't know if I had to specify
this I won't lie it took me like an hour
or two and probably about 18 revisions
to this to get it to work because I was
doing this for the first time and I was
reading the documentation trying new
things so it's possible that this is
just already in the environment
variables and if you leave it as default
then it will be fine if you actually go
to like checkout this is the checkout
repository you know that's where I got
this from so you can see that it's a
repository name with owner but the
default is GitHub repository so I'm
assuming that I don't need this but
nevertheless it's here now sub modules I
did have to set to true and lfs I had to
set to true because these both default
TOA as you can see uh then I set up a
specific version of python 3.12 this is
what required those admin privileges for
some reason for the life of me I
couldn't get it to find existing python
installations I figured this probably
isn't too bad because this will install
it if it's not there I assume it
probably gets cashed somewhere in the
runner so that doesn't have to keep
installing in every run but I think this
is a a great little thing to have
because it ensures that you have a valid
working version of python and it's the
right version as well that you know is
compatible Ms build it will then find
this default architecture was x86 so I
changed it to x64 this doesn't install M
build it just finds the existing
installation without much trouble then
we have a setup step over here so what
this does is from the scripts directory
if we actually take a look at the root
kind of Hazel repository we have a
scripts directory and then we have this
kind of setup.bat which just calls
python setup.py so this is the kind of
setup script that will make sure that
you know we have the right version of
vcon installed it'll run premake to
generate the visual studio project inst
solution files it'll pull like sub
modules it'll just make sure that
everything's kind of set up for you so
that's me calling it here with you know
inside this working directory which is
going to be the checked out rout of the
repository but then we're changing into
the script directory because it has to
be run from there if you use this pipe
here you can specify as many lines as
you want of different commands so that's
what I'm doing here and then so after
this step we now have the visual studio
project files and the solution file
generated so we can now call Ms build so
this step is just called build again
inside this working directory it will
call Ms build with the solution file
path which is specified over here Hazels
sln that's our solution /m just means
that it will build the projects in
parallel and then we have an actual
property here which is our configuration
set to you can see matrix. build
configuration so that is this so
whatever kind of variation of this
Matrix is that is being run at the
moment whether that be debug release or
dist that is the kind of variable that
goes in here and then we're also
outputting a log file this isn't
strictly necessary because we'll be able
to see all of the logs over here in
GitHub but it doesn't hurt to just have
a text file with your log on the actual
computer so that's what this is and
that's it that's that's our entire
workflow at the moment and so the way
this works is when someone pushes to the
dev Branch it will automatically start
like one of these workflow runs so you
can see for example this was me
yesterday uh you know trying to work
this out this was the first build I
deleted the ones between 1 and 18 that's
how many attempts it took me to actually
get this running uh and then you can see
it's going to run all of this and that's
how long it took so every time Dev is
pushed to it will basically communicate
with the self-hosted runner in this case
that we've installed on this computer
and what it does is a completely kind of
clean from scratch execution of this
workflow so over here inside this
actions run directory there's this
underscore work folder which it asks you
what you want to call it that's the
default name and then inside here you
can see we have Hazel Hazel and then
this is the checkout of the repository
now it nukes this it deletes this every
single time that runs oh there was one
thing that I forgot to mention and
that's this fail fast false strategy so
this is important because since there
are multiple kind of build
configurations here it won't run them in
order cuz as I mentioned they can be
parallel I didn't actually see it being
run in parallel here maybe I have to do
something else for that but either way
it randomly selects one of these to run
first and if it fails it stops all the
other actions so it doesn't proceed to
test the other configurations I didn't
want that happening because sometimes
like a debug build will fail but release
and dist will work or dist will fail and
debug and release will work work so I
want to know if all of them are broken
or if just one of them is broken or you
know something like that so fail fast
means that it's not going to bought
everything if one of them fails so that
was important as well because before I
updated it it was it was failing fast
now immediately once I kind of enabled
this yesterday a real world use case
actually just naturally happened which
is great like this was useful
immediately because you can see that I
finally fixed renderer 2D I did a live
stream about this uh it'll be on my
channel unplug Channel by the way the V
for this but I was working on like
extending render a 2d in Hazel so it can
dynamically resize how much it's able to
render and you can see here that the the
debug uh configuration failed that's the
one that it happened to run first and so
you can see it didn't do the other ones
but if we look over here we we can look
at the logs we can see that it failed
why did it fail because check this out
we have a compile error it's saying quad
vertex buffer base Undeclared identifier
so that actually prompted me to take a
look at that because I made the rookie
mistake of not compiling my code in all
configurations I didn't compile it in
debug I was just using the release
configuration I assumed it would work uh
and then that led me to push this which
did actually succeed and that was me
removing an assert because this assert
only gets compiled for debug builds it
gets stripped out of release or
distribution builds and this was using a
variable that no longer existed and in
fact this whole thing is kind of
obsolete now because it uses a different
system anyway but the fact that it was
in an assert meant that the code was
stripped in the release build so of
course it wasn't a compile error but it
wasn't debug so well done CI for
catching that because I was obviously
too lazy to build in all configurations
and you can see that you know all three
jobs were completed successfully
debugged dist and release you can click
on them you can look at all the actions
so for example here's us uh you know
installing python uh here's us finding
like Ms build here's us running the kind
of python setup scripts to generate all
of the project files and you can see
there actually is an error that I still
have to fix for that as well but it's
not overly critical and then here's the
actual build so this is the big juicy
one that that this is the entire log
from it actually you know compiling
every single like CPP file and building
the actual projects with 41 warnings
zero errors and that's kind of it so
anyone on the team can obviously access
these logs they can see what's going on
if they've pushed something they can see
what the error is this is going to
become a whole new level of useful when
we expand this to also run on Linux
because a lot of times you might not
have like a Linux PC available for
testing so you push something you think
it's fine but then turns out it builds
on windows and not on Linux and the fact
that it can obviously get automatically
tested is amazing not to mention when we
take this a step further and we don't
just build it but we run it and we test
it and we run all the different
automated tests that we have because
that's kind of going to be step two
we'll improve it with each release so
that we can also focus on developing
features for Hazel and getting all that
running so this is kind of like Mark one
of this system and yeah it's amazing uh
hopefully this video was helpful if you
wanted to set up a system like this for
yourselves I hope I hope this was fairly
thorough as I mentioned like the only
real two issues that I had was initially
just making sure that I changed the kind
of permissions from this to this so that
I could run these external actions as
well and then also making sure that the
actual Runner application running as a
Windows service had the appropriate
administrative privileges to do
administrative things hope you guys
enjoyed the journey if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button
below you can also get access to Hazel
and help support its development by
going to patreon.com Theo and I will see
you guys next time goodbye y